I think you know social media is such a
great tool sure social media is a great
tool but now Kim Kardashian is being
fined over one million dollars for
allegedly not disclosing she was being
paid to promote cryptocurrency on
Instagram I
exhausted this game's founder must pay a
whopping 1.26 million bucks in a
settlement agreement with the Securities
and Exchange Commission after she was
charged with unlawfully touting a crypto
company without letting her 330 million
plus followers know how much cash she
was getting in exchange for the post it
wasn't the plan on Monday the SEC
explained in a press release Kim is
paying the fine without admitting to or
denying their findings the agency also
revealed that Kim agreed to not promote
any crypto companies for three years and
will cooperate in its ongoing
investigation you just gotta roll with
it and if you are wondering how much Kim
got paid for the insta story post thanks
to the SCC we've got the answer drumroll
please
250
000 it's a lot yeah a quarter of a
million dollars people the SEC explained
in a statement quote Federal Securities
laws are clear that any celebrity or
other individual who promotes a crypto
asset security must disclose the nature
source and amount of compensation they
received in exchange for the promotion
as for Kim's settlement it includes
about two hundred and sixty thousand
dollars in discouragement Kim's profit
for the Post plus interest as well as a
one million dollar penalty it was a
whirlwind and in a statement to ET the
reality star's lawyer explained that she
is pleased to have resolved the whole
ordeal adding that she has fully
cooperated since the very beginning and
wanted to get this matter behind her of
course Kim is one of the reigning Queens
of social media and when ET sat down
with her back in 2018 she said when it
comes to her past posts she she has no
regrets I'm never not proud of anything
that I have shared you know but at the
time it might be something that I was so
excited to post and now I could look
back and be like well I might not post
that today but I have like no regrets at
that time I was really feeling it so
just don't be impulsive you know think
it through think about if you want
people to know this information because
it'll always be there
[Music]
thank you